hey David if Brett Kavanaugh had been
accused of attempted murder by two to
three women would Republicans still have
confirmed him you know it's an
interesting question because it makes me
think back to when Donald Trump said I
could shoot people on Fifth Avenue and I
would still not lose any supporters
here's the thing let's grant that
attempted murder is a worse crime than
attempted sexual assault maybe people in
the audience disagree but for our
conversation and sort of implicit in the
question is the idea that attempted
murder is a worse crime than attempted
sexual assault would Republicans still
have confirmed him I almost think it
would have been easier because they
would have said hold on hold on a second
you're telling me he tried to kill
people and there's no police report and
there's no this and there's no that with
sexual assault we know why we often have
incidents unreported because of stigma
because of fear because of shame because
of embarrassment because of the
expectation that you're not going to be
believed because of the expectation that
the person won't be held accountable
because so many aren't with attempted
murder it's much harder to make the case
as to why it was never actually reported
to police or anything like that so I
actually it's an interesting question
because the question goes to
is there anything Republicans wouldn't
have ignored to just push this guy
through no matter how horrible but in a
sense I feel like it would have been
easier to write off yeah I think it'll
be easier to but for a different reason
when it comes to attempted rape
attempted sexual assault there's never
any reason or excuse for that
but murder I mean maybe they could come
up with something that at a visceral
level we would sympathize with Cavanaugh
or self different thing yeah it was self
defense or you know this person screwed
them from a financial standpoint or from
a personal standpoint and they would be
able to make that emotional appeal to
the voters and get around it a little
bit easier in fact imagine that the
circumstances were that Brett Cavanaugh
was involved in some kind of love
triangle not a Devil's one necessarily
but just the size the drinking game a
triangle that's a drinking game anyway a
triangle of some kind and the other dude
in the Triangle came to Brett Kavanaugh
and a
hacked him and Brett Cavanaugh responded
no no he didn't kill the guy but he
responded with strong enough force that
it could colloquially be called
attempted murder you think Republicans
are gonna shut the guy down when he says
listen this guy came after me I did take
my gun out I did fire the gun as the guy
ran away I didn't hit him yeah you could
call it attempted murder but it was in
self-defense that's ultimately what it
was not a single Republican votes
against him for them is a single
Republican no question about him
interesting question but I actually
think it in some way it would have made
it easier for Brett Kavanaugh to be
confirmed sadly that's sort of the
situation that were in that is it for
this week other than the bonus show very
solid audience questions this week I'm
feeling kind of good about reviving
audience question there was a resurgence
I think there really is there really is
keep sending yours in if there I got a
lot of bad ones I will admit but we did
get some good ones as well so keep
sending them in and we will work in the
good ones we've got a great bonus show
for you today Google Plus is getting
shut down global temperatures may be
connected with mental health issues and
we will also talk about a restraining
order against extremists very aggressive
vegan activists outside of a Berkeley
California
Whole Foods store we will get immediate
reaction from vegan producer Pat and
much more ww join pakman.com become a
patron to access the bonus show at
patreon.com slash david pakman show